-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it seems like
there's so much
going on right now.
Everyone's gearing up for
the midterms.
The World Series is heating up.
The top-10 songs in the country
are all by Taylor Swift.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, Stouffer's is releasing
its own Bloody Mary mix
that tastes like lasagna.
There's a lot to go over.
Let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
First up, the midterms.
They're less than a week away.
Republicans are trying to win
back control of
the House and the Senate,
while the Democrats
want to hold on to both.
Two sides going head-to-head,
kind of like...
the World Series.
Tonight was Game 4 between
the Phillies and the Astros.
Both teams are doing
everything they can
to prove that they're the best
in the country.
Speaking of the best
in the country...
Taylor Swift.
She's the first artist
to hold all top-10 spots
in the Billboard 100 at once.
That must feel good.
And if you want to feel good,
too, maybe don't try...
Stouffer's new lasagna-flavored
Bloody Mary mix.
It's vodka mixed with lasagna,
topped with a rim
of shredded mozzarella.
It's the perfect drink for
anyone who wants to black out
and forget all about...
the midterms.
It's a stressful time.
President Biden has been
touring the country
trying to rally support
for Democrats,
but the only tour most people
care about is...
Taylor's.
She announced her Eras Tour
this week.
Tickets aren't available yet,
but Swifties
are losing their minds,
foaming at the mouth,
which are also side effects
when you drink...
Stouffer's lasagna-flavored
Bloody Mary mix.
Look at this thing.
It's like a lasagna smoothie.
It's like a V8 from hell.
If you drink one of these,
you might get the...
runs.
You need runs
if you want to win.
Philly's going to go nuts
if they win, by the way.
Police are already racing
to grease up light poles.
Speaking of races and polls...
the midterms.
Dr. Oz is running for office
in Pennsylvania,
and you'll be
in a doctor's office
after drinking...
alcoholic lasagna.
In conclusion...
here we go...
time to vote...
what a show...
just no.
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, speaking of the midterms
and the World Series,
yesterday, during a speech,
President Biden
said that Phillies fans
are the most obnoxious fans
in the world.
Yeah. Meanwhile, Jill was like,
"Uh, Joe, is there something
you want to tell me or..."
And this was big.
Tonight, Biden delivered
a prime-time speech
from Capitol Hill
about the midterm elections
and said it could take
several days
for all of the votes to be
counted in some swing states.
And, unfortunately,
after these past two years,
every state is a swing state.
Yeah, a lot of experts
are predicting
a red wave on election day.
And you can tell Biden
is nervous,
because he already hired
Rudy Giuliani
to challenge the results.
Well, everyone's
talking about the midterms,
and a lot of races
are coming down to the wire.
Let me explain it all to you
with the "Midterms in Pictures."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
The midterm elections
are next Tuesday.
We're going to find out
if Congress is going
red, blue, or a...
different color altogether.
After months of campaigning,
voters are...
tired and cranky.
Watching commercial after
commercial has driven them
completely...
insane.
At this point, they'd be fine if
every candidate just...
disappeared.
But the election is
important for our democracy,
for our future, and for...
millions of kids.
Now, of course,
not everyone can win.
The losers will have to
take it on the...
chin and get sent away on an...
involuntary vacation.
Meanwhile, the winners will
feel great until
their poll numbers start to...
slide down.
The important thing
is that everyone votes
no matter what state
you live in,
because voting is the best thing
about America since it was...
born in 1776.
That was "Midterms in Pictures."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, listen to this.
According to prosecutors,
after storming the Capitol
on January 6th,
a group of rioters spent over
$400 at the Olive Garden.
That explains why
they changed their slogan to...
Switching gears.
Did you guys see this?
Adele just revealed
that her name
is actually pronounced "A-Dale."
Adele's name is
pronounced "A-Dale."
Or As her fans put it, "A-no."
They're sticking with Adele.
That's right.
Adele's name
is pronounced A-Dale.
I had no idea.
Did you guys know that?
-[ Scoffs ]
Of course I knew that.
I never mispronounce any
celebrity names.
Come on.
Give me any celebrity name.
-Okay, I guess I can test
you real quick.
I mean, who's this?
-Oh, that's easy.
Michael B'Jordan.
-Okay. Who's this?
-Disney Chanel. Come on.
Give me some harder ones, man.
Rapid-fire me. Come on.
-Okay, I'm not sure this is a
great idea, but here we go.
Who's this?
-Okay. Hug My Aunt.
Buns of Steel.
Gluten-free Mozzarella.
Macaroni and Cheese.
Oh, Moderna Pfizer.
Jake Gylla-Pudding Pops
and his sister,
Maggie Goo Goo Dolls.
-Wait. Why would their names be
pronounced differently?
-Well, it's like "Roozevelt"
and Roosevelt, you know?
Come on. Keep 'em coming.
-Alright, what about her?
-Okay. Hilarious Spanx.
Penis Quaalude.
Oh, Anus and Arms.
Colon Fart.
-Alright, I think that's enough.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate -- Thank you.
Thank you. No, that's good.
Steve Higgins, everybody.
That's more than -- Thank you.
-Adele.
-Well, here's some fun news.
This year's Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree
has been selected.
Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The tree is moving from
the suburbs to the big city.
Right now,
its parents are telling it
to always carry its wallet
in its front pocket.
That's right --
the tree is a Norway spruce
that's 50 feet wide
and 82 feet tall.
Although, it put 85 feet tall
on its Timber profile.
There you go.
And, finally, it's time for --
Yeah, Timber, yeah.
It's time for
our latest installment
of "Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go, everybody.
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
♪ Polls ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, this first poll asked...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
This next poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Wow. This next one asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next poll asked...
[ Rimshot ]
-Come on!
-This next poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
-What? 80%?!
-Yeah, 80%.
-80%?
-80% said they do that.
-Wow.
That's how they eat it?
Sideways?
-Yeah. This next poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
This next poll asked...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
This last one asked...